Pancho Villa was one of the most divisive
figures in history.
To millions he was the Mexican Robin Hood,
to others a ruthless terrorist who killed
without conscience.
What is without doubt is that he rose from
humble beginnings to become one of the most
famous Mexicans in history, playing a vital
role in the decade that shaped modern Mexico.
In this week’s Biographics, we discover
the real story of Pancho Villa.
Beginnings
There is a lot of mystery surrounding the
early life of the man who became Pancho Villa.
Most historians believe that he was born on
June 5th 1878 in the tiny village of Rancho
de la Coyotada in the state of Durango, Mexico.
His birth name was Jose Doroteo Arango Arambula.
When he was a few years old, his father, Agustin
Arango, died.
This meant that Doroteo, the oldest of five
children, had to start working on the hacienda.
Getting up at three o’clock in the morning,
he had to walk for ten miles to start work
at five.
The work consisted of planting corn and running
errands.
Villa later claimed that he never attended
a day of school in his life.
When not working, he liked to play cards and
was often getting into fights with his peers.
During his teens he held a number of jobs
including muleskinner, bricklayer and butcher.
Then, at the age of 16, he moved to Chihuahua
for work.
The story goes that two years later he returned
to his home town in order to hunt down a man
named Agustin Lopez Negrete, who had raped
his sister.
He apparently found the rapist and killed
him.
This episode is said to have set him on his
life of crime.
He fled to the Sierra Madre mountains and
joined a group of bandits, changing his name
to Pancho Villa.
The bandits, who numbered between 40 and 50
men, raided the ranches of the wealthy to
steal cattle and horses.
They lived in the mountains and trained as
guerrilla fighters.
Their reputation as fighters against the system
established them as freedom fighters in the
minds of the poor, who gave them shelter and
warned them when the rurales, or rural police
force, were closing in.
In 1902, Villa was captured by the rurales.
According to the practice of the times, he
was inducted into the Federal Army.
He spent several months in the army and then
deserted, heading back into the hills to rejoin
his gang.
Around this time, he killed an army officer,
which made him one of the most wanted men
in northern Mexico.
A reward of ten thousand pesos was placed
on his head.
Pancho became the leader of his bandit group
and continued to lead increasingly violent
raids upon the wealthy.
The legend says that he would sometimes risk
capture by walking openly through the streets
of Chihuahua to distribute money to the poor.
In so doing, he won the loyalty of the people,
who helped to protect him from the authorities.
Revolution
In 1910, Mexico seemed to be a model of democratic
stability.
Porfiro Diaz had been president for 30 years
and the country was celebrating 100 years
of independence.
But Diaz ruled with an iron fist and the elections
that were held every four years were merely
a façade to appease foreign governments.
Ninety percent of the country lived in poverty.
Since 1906, there had been a number of worker
rebellions against the conditions they were
forced to exist under.
Each one had been forcibly put down by the
Diaz regime.
A number of intellectuals began writing against
the regime, including a man named Francisco
Madero, who decided to run for President in
1910.
When his campaign began to gather momentum,
however, President Diaz had Madero arrested
and thrown in prison.
The mock election went ahead and Diaz was
re-elected for the seventh time.
Madero managed to escape from prison and fled
to the United States.
From there he began planning for revolution.
Meanwhile, down in Chihuahua, Pancho Villa
had established a reputation as a kind of
Mexican Robin Hood, a champion of the underprivileged.
But he was also known as a wild man, a ruthless
killer who would shed blood with impunity.
Seeking respectability, he met with a supporter
of Francisco Madero by the name of Abraham
Gonzalez.
By aligning himself with Madero, Gonzalez
told Pancho, he would be able to re-invent
himself as a legitimate man of the people.
Villa agreed and he threw the support of his
bandit group behind the revolutionary cause.
By now Pancho had developed a strong hatred
for the regime of Porfiro Diaz, along with
the exploitary landowners and the rurales
who had been hunting him for more than a decade.
He and his men brought skills to the revolutionary
cause that had been honed over years of raiding,
fighting and evading the authorities.
In battle, Pancho fought like a man possessed
and now that he had an established cause,
he was even more ferocious.
He also proved himself as a master of military
tactics, brilliantly marshaling his small
band against much larger government forces.
On one occasion, at the battle of Escobas,
Pancho put hats upon planted sticks in order
to fool the rurales into thinking that he
had a much larger army than he actually did.
By the beginning of 1911, that army had grown
to more than 400 people and was racking up
decisive victories over the Federal Army at
such places as Naica, Camargo, and Pilar de
Conchos.
In early 1911, there was a challenge to the
revolutionary leadership of Madero from the
ultra-radical Mexican Liberal Party.
To put down the challenge, Madero turned to
Pancho, who moved in and arrested the leaders
of the party.
A grateful Madero rewarded Villa by making
him a colonel of his revolutionary army.
In May, 1911, Madero’s 3000 strong force,
with Villa at the forefront, laid siege to
the key border city of Ciudad Juarez.
The town was guarded by 500 Federal troops,
along with 300 civilian auxiliaries and local
police.
The fighting went on for two days at the end
of which the Federals surrendered.
On May 25th, with his armies being defeated
and public opinion unanimously against him,
President Diaz resigned and fled into exile.
A free and fair election was held in which
Francisco Madero was elected President.
Madero signed the Treaty of Ciudad Juarez
by which the Federal Army would remain in
place.
He, therefore, ordered the disbanding of his
rebel army to return to their pre-war lives.
Madero allowed the structure of the Diaz government
to remain.
To Pancho Villa this was a fatal error, and
he let his feelings be known, telling Madero
. . .
You sir, have destroyed the revolution.
It’s simple; this bunch of dandies have
made a fool of you, and this will eventually
cost us our necks, yours included.
Division
Villa and his fellow revolutionaries were
also incensed that Madero refused to distribute
seized hacienda land to veterans of the struggle
as payment for services rendered.
Villa became increasingly critical of Madero’s
actions, especially his putting a former supporter
of deposed President Diaz as Minister of War.
Even more outspoken, was a fellow revolutionary
leader by the name of Pascual Orozco.
In March, 1912, Orozco led a rebellion against
the new regime.
Madero called on Villa to put it down.
Despite being urged by Orozco to join the
revolt, Pancho led his army of 400 in conjunction
with Federal forces in a series of decisive
victories that quashed the rebellion.
Following the victory against Orozco, Villa’s
band joined up with Federal militia in the
city of Torreon in the state of Coahuila.
The Federal commander, General Victoriano
Huerta, detested Villa.
He was initially welcoming, showering him
with praise and awarding him an honorary generalship.
But the pleasantries didn’t last long, with
Huerta accusing Pancho of stealing a horse.
With his honor publicly impugned, Villa responded
by slapping the general.
This was the pretext that Huerta was after
and he promptly had Villa arrested and charged
with insubordination.
An execution by firing squad was ordered.
Word of the affair reached President Madero
who telegraphed Huerta and ordered him not
to execute Villa but to keep him as a prisoner.
Villa was sent to the Belem Prison in Mexico
City.
While incarcerated there he learned to read
and write under the guidance of a fellow prisoner.
In June, he was transferred to a prison in
Santiago.
Six months later he escaped, jumping onboard
a train bound for the United States.
On January 2nd, 1913 he arrived in El Paso,
Texas.
While in prison, Pancho had learned of a planned
coup against Madero.
He attempted to get a warning message through
to the president, but it never arrived in
time.
On February 22nd, 1913, Madero was gunned
down on the orders of General Huerta, the
man who had come so close to executing Villa
a year earlier.
Huerta now installed himself as the President
of Mexico.
Villa was incensed at this series of events.
Even though he had become disillusioned with
his actions upon gaining power, he still viewed
Francisco Madero as the apostle of democracy
and his personal role model.
Now that Huerta, his personal enemy, was in
power he knew that he had to return to Mexico.
He felt the mantle of completing the dream
of democracy that Madero had instilled in
him was upon his shoulders.
Okay, now just before we get into Villa’s
really brutal phase, it’s time or a quick
word from our sponsor Scribd.
Deposing Presidents
The Mexican people were just as upset as Villa
at the turn of events.
Except for the wealthy businessmen who were
relieved by this ‘return to order’, the
vast majority viewed Huerta as a ‘jackal’
who had stolen the Presidency.
In March of 1913, Pancho Villa returned to
Mexico intent on avenging the murder of Madero
and relieving his country of the tyranny of
Huerta.
He later recalled . . .
That night I had eight men with me, and we
had no definite plan but had decided to make
for my old haunts in the Sierra Madre mountains,
where I knew I could find men to follow me.
We had one sack of flour, two small packages
of coffee and some salt.
That was all our food supply.
Of course, we were all well armed, but had
little ammunition.
Villa’s small band began making lightning
raids upon the Federal forces that were garrisoned
in Northern Mexican towns and forts.
Slowly the were able to accumulate the arms
and supplies that they needed.
Within a week, Villa’s band had grown to
more than a hundred men and within three months
it had morphed into a legitimate army of 18,000
troops.
In battle, Villa proved to be ruthless.
His standard policy was to kill prisoners.
A lucky few would only be spared by the intervention
of his lieutenants.
In contrast to this brutal side of his nature,
though, Pancho had a strong social conscience.
For two months in 1913, he held the position
of Governor of Chihuahua.
He expropriated land from the wealthy to distribute
to the poor, opened several schools and enacted
laws to protect widows and orphans.
On Christmas Day, 1913, he gathered the poor
of Chihuahua together and gave them each fifteen
pesos.
By such actions, he became the hero and savior
of the underclass.
By early 1914, Villa had control over the
northern part of Mexico.
Handing over the governorship to his lieutenant,
he began the march south to Mexico City where
Huerta sat in the presidential chair.
As he swept south, he conquered everything
in his way, gaining a reputation as the Centaur
of the North.
By June his army had grown to 50,000, most
of whom were on horseback.
By now it was a fully-fledged army, with mobile
hospitals and recruits from other countries,
including the United States.
At the head of this, the largest revolutionary
army in the history of the Americas, stood
Pancho Villa, a leader with great charisma
who at the same earned the respect and fear
of his men.
Villa developed a military strategy that proved
enormously successful.
Day and night, he would pour a continuous
frontal assault against the enemy line, supported
by cavalry troops.
The attacks were continually rolling with
troops at the front being replaced by those
behind.
This gave the defenders no time to rest, resulting
in them almost always being overwhelmed by
the sustained force of the attack.
Villa also established offices within his
army similar to government departments.
He had an office of foreign affairs, who were
particularly focused on reaching out to President
Woodrow Wilson for US aid.
His financial committee made contact with
wealthy landowners to assure them that they
would be mistreated once victory was achieved.
The United States offered support to the revolutionary
cause through a round-about means.
Villa sold livestock and other products to
the US, which provided the funds with which
to purchase American weapons and ammunition.
It was this flow of weaponry that enabled
the rebel army to match up to the Federal
forces.
In recognition of the aid being received from
north of the border, Vila ensured that no
American property was confiscated.
Positive press in American media resulted,
with the Washington Times reporting in January,
1914 about Villa that ’he is now carrying
on a campaign of modern and humane warfare’.
The media, in fact, fell in love with Villa,
with one editor writing . . .
Villa is without the possibility of any doubt
the greatest leader Mexico has ever had.
His method fighting is astonishingly like
Napoleon’s.
Villa instituted some telling innovations
in Mexican warfare.
He was the first to leave the women and children
behind and force the pace of his army with
raids, marching far away from his base.
He would abandon his supply trains and head
far out in search of the enemy.
He was also the first to stage night time
attacks, which became especially devastating
to the enemy.
In the spring of 1914, the two key cities
of Torreon and Zacatecas were taken.
These victories brought the regime to its
knees, with Huerta fleeing into exile on July,
14th, 1914.
The Federal Army collapsed, leaving the revolutionaries
to fill the vacuum.
Into the presidency now stepped Venustiano
Carranza, a former hacienda owner who brought
his forces into Mexico City ahead of Villa.
Yet, it was Pancho Villa who was the hero
of the revolution.
Wherever he went, people would yell out ‘Viva
Villa!’
Ousting Carranza
The struggle, however, was not yet over.
Villa and his fellow revolutionary leader,
Emiliano Zapata joined forces to oust Carranza,
who they had never intended to take the helm.
On December 6th, 1914, Villa rode at the head
of 50,000 men, alongside Zapata with his 15,000.
By then Carranza had already fled the capital.
Pancho Villa was now at the height of his
power.
Wearing a navy blue suit and a cap with the
eagle of the Mexican flag, he rode through
the city as the masses turned out to shower
him with praise.
He went to the presidential palace and sat
on the Presidential chair, but only long enough
to have his picture taken.
He never served as the President of Mexico,
though he could have easily won an election
at that time.
A council between the various fighting factions
failed to bring a consensus and Villa continued
to lead his army against pockets of rebellion.
Alvaro Obregon was a supporter of Carranza
who won a series of decisive battles against
Villa’s army.
Pancho was outsmarted by Obregon and many
of his men were killed.
He was forced to retreat to his base in the
northern Sierra Madre mountains.
In a few months of fierce fighting the invincible
army that had marched into Mexico City had
been reduced to a rag tag mob of just a few
hundred men.
Violent Streak
A change now came over Pancho Villa.
His violent streak was fully unleashed.
In the time of San Pedro de la Cueva, he brought
all of the men in town into the middle of
the town and killed them all, personally shooting
the local priest in the head.
Then, in Santa Isabella, he shot several American
miners.
The Americans now distanced themselves from
Villa and recognized the reinstituted Carranza
government.
At round 4 in the morning on the March 9th,
1916, Villa, incensed that President Wilson
had legitimized the Carranza government, led
a force of one hundred men across the border
and into the town of Columbus, New Mexico.
They attacked the town of 600 inhabitants
from four directions, shooting indiscriminately,
looting and burning buildings.
Villa, however, had chosen the wrong town.
The 13th US Cavalry was stationed there, with
4 machine guns and 400 highly trained soldiers.
The majority of his men were killed, but Villa
managed to get away, leaving a trail of destruction
in his wake.
The American response to the unprovoked Columbus
attack as overwhelming.
10,000 troops were put on trains and sent
to the border with the single objective of
capturing the fugitive Pancho Villa.
At the head of the American forces was John
Pershing, who led his troops, along with Apache
Indian scouts 350 miles across the border
in search of Villa.
Into every village that he went, Pershing
would yell out, ‘Where is Pancho Villa?’
Every time the locals would provide false
information.
On several occasions portions of Pershing’s
army skirmished with Villa and his tiny band.
On one occasion, Pancho was shot in the leg.
In April, American newspapers reported that
he had died as a result of the leg being infected.
The reality was that Villa was still very
much alive, though badly wounded and hiding
out in a cave in the Sierra Madres.
Pershing’s expedition managed to capture
weaponry and horses but failed in its objective
of bringing Pancho in.
With the American’s having withdrawn, Villa
reverted to his guerrilla fighting ways.
He still had the support of the people and
was determined to continue fighting against
Carranza’s regime.
Then, in 1920, with another coup in the offing,
President Carranza was killed as he fled to
the Gulf of Mexico with the national treasure.
Villa saw this turn of events as his opportunity
to come to a peace settlement with the new
regime.
He rode for 13 days to the city of Sabinas,
Coahuila and telegraphed new president Adolfo
de la Huerta requesting an amnesty.
Huerta agreed, grateful that the threat of
a Villa overthrow was nullified.
Retirement and Death
Vila was given a 25,000 acre farm in Canutillo.
He brought 200 of his men with him, who he
immediately put to work on improving the run-down
property.
Within a short time, Canutillo was turned
into a commune, with a school, wheat, corn
and bean crops that were able to support a
large community of people.
Villa got up early each day to supervise the
work and spend time in the school house.
He hardly ever left the farm, fearful of assassination
attempts.
On the morning of July 20th, 1923 Villa did
leave his ranch.
He went to Parral to visit one of his wives
and to withdraw money to pay his workers.
As his Dodge vehicle was driving through a
deserted part of town, dozens of snipers opened
up, filling the car with more than forty bullet
holes, nine of which smashed into Pancho Villa’s
body.
His death was instantaneous.
Yet even in death, Villa did not find peace.
Three years after his burial in Parral, his
tomb was ransacked, the corpse removed and
Pancho’s head cut off.
Souvenir hunters had also taken pieces of
the coffin and some of his bones.
In 2010, the Wall Street Journal reported
that his right index finger was being offered
in a pawn shop in El Paso.
The asking price was $9,500.